(relaxing music)
- [Johnny] I'm looking
at a reservoir right now
that is full of water
from a different country.
- [Male Speaker] For a
country that is surrounded
by water, you might not expect Cyprus
to be suffering a shortage.
The answer, pump it in;
the question, where from?
(soothing electronic music)
- But the reality is this
water is not just water.
It represents something so much bigger.
This entire project is happening
for a very specific reason.
(funky music)
The flags on the side
of this dam represent
this joint venture between Turkey,
and the so-called Turkish
Republic of Northern Cyprus.
A country that doesn't technically exist,
but Turkey wants it to exist.
And that's why they
built this umbilical cord
from their country, to the country
they're trying to make a real country.
(funky music)
I want to talk to the
people who live here,
to understand what it feels like
to live in a country that doesn't exist.
(energetic electronic music)
- [Male Speaker] Tanks of the Turkish Army
are about to compete
their victory in Cyprus.
The Turkish army has conquered
that part of the island,
which she thinks should
belong to the Turks.
- [Male Speaker 2] There are
no trade and customs barriers
between North and South, neither side
recognizes the other's ports of entry.
- [Male Speaker] Turkey could
draw the Southern boundary
of what would virtually be a
new state of Turkish Cyprus.
- Hey, before we dive into
this video about Turkey
and Turkish Cypriots, I
want to thank the sponsor
of today's video, who
supported my trip to Cyprus,
and generally supports this channel.
BetterHelp is a platform
that is making therapy
more accessible to everyone.
I am a big proponent of therapy.
I've been in therapy for now two years,
and it has changed my life.
Finding a therapist is
often hard and complicated,
and there are long wait times,
and complicated situations with insurance.
With BetterHelp, what
you do is you go online,
you fill out some information,
and BetterHelp will assess
your needs, and match you
with your own licensed
professional therapist.
You can start communicating
within 48 hours,
which, if you've ever
looked for a therapist,
the traditional way is a very short time.
This isn't a self-help program,
it's not a crisis hotline.
This is professional therapy
done securely online.
BetterHelp has a network
of over 20,000 therapists,
which means you're gonna
have a much larger network
to choose from, than if
you were just choosing
from therapists in your local area.
And among this network, there
is a broad range of expertise.
So you can find the
therapist that fits for you.
So BetterHelp makes it
easy to switch, for free,
to a new therapist until
you find the right fit.
This service is available
for clients worldwide.
If you want to try this out,
you can get 10% off your
first month of BetterHelp
by going to the link in my description,
it's BetterHelp.com/JohnnyHarris.
Go click the link and join
over the 1 million people
taking charge of their mental health
with the help of an
experienced professional.
Thank you, BetterHelp, for
supporting this channel,
for supporting my reporting in journalism.
And now let's get back
to the island of Cyprus.
- [Johnny] My hope is that this pipeline
will make a lot more
sense in like 10 minutes.
By then, you will understand
what this really means,
both geopolitically, and on a human level.
It'll also make sense how
this pipeline is connected
to the people who live here.
Like this guy, Vedat, a Turkish Cypriot
who sometimes wishes he
could get off this island.
- I'm not hugely ambitious,
but I do want to leave-
- Yeah.
- if I can.
- [Johnny] But for all
of that to make sense,
you have to understand the
Turkish side of the story
of what happened in 1974.
(slow piano music)
- (speaking foreign language)
- [Johnny] The Cypriots became independent
from the British in 1960.
Soon, the two groups on
the island were clashing.
The Greek Cypriot majority
bullying and massacring
the Turkish Cypriot
minority, who were driven out
of their villages into
camps around the country.
This was one reason why, in 1974,
Turkey felt emboldened to intervene,
to save the Turkish Cypriots
from this persecution.
- [Male Speaker] It's no
wonder that the Turks rejoice,
no wonder that the siege is
but a bad memory from a past,
which will never return.
- (speaking foreign language)
- [Johnny] Turkey took over
the North of this island,
forcing Greek Cypriots to
leave their homes empty,
only to be filled by Turkish Cypriots
coming north for protection.
(overlapping background voices)
- [Male Speaker] They won't return
while the Turks are there.
(tense piano music)
- My new mechanic friend, Dogay,
came to this village that
used to be a Greek village,
but was now empty from
everyone having fled.
And he found a home.
So this is- just moved in here.
- [Male Speaker 3] They moved in.
- [Johnny] And the
Turkish military gave him,
and his family, a home to live in.
Oh, this is the house
that they moved into.
- [Male Speaker 3] Yes.
- When they arrived to this house,
they found all the mundane
things of a normal life:
homework from a high
school geometry class.
- [Male Speaker 3] This is schoolwork.
- [Johnny] Schoolwork?
Furniture and art, lots
of art, original art.
The people living here
must've been artists.
- (speaking foreign language)
- [Johnny] How did it
feel to arrive to a house
that had people's art
and belongings in it?
- (speaking foreign language)
(energetic electronic music)
- [Johnny] By August,
1974, Turkey had taken
all of this land, which was now considered
a safe haven for Turkish Cypriots.
But the world didn't like this,
they were calling this
an illegal occupation.
So Turkey held fast to their
line of being protectors.
- [Male Speaker] Generals
of the Turkish high command,
their victory complete, arrived
in triumph to acknowledge
the greetings of those they'd saved.
(energetic electronic music with piano)
- (speaking foreign language)
- [Male Speaker 3] But then
freedoms are never given.
You have to take 'em.
I'm afraid we had to do that,
only Turkey could've helped us.
- [Johnny] Turkish Cypriots
felt saved by Turkey,
but Turkey's motives for
taking over all of this land
wasn't just about saving
100,000 or so Turkish Cypriots.
(tense electronic music)
Starting in 1974, Turkey set
about on a decades-long project
of turning this land
that they just took over,
into a country-like space,
that could help fulfill
Turkey's bigger objectives in the region.
While also ensuring that
this 35% of the island
would never be reunited
with the rest of the island.
(energetic electronic music)
There's this phrase we use
in international relations,
called, "Facts on the ground".
It describes what geopolitical
situations actually look like
on the ground, versus
what they technically
should look like, according
to laws and treaties.
So while all this land in Northern Cyprus,
technically on paper,
belongs to the EU country
called the Republic of Cyprus, in reality,
the facts on the ground say otherwise.
The facts that we're
talking about, in this case,
are usually humans, real people
occupying space and building
physical infrastructure.
It's the same reason why
Israel subsidizes people
to live out here in the West Bank,
to make it harder to ever
create a Palestinian State.
Or why Russia sends hundreds of people
to this remote island, to work
a coal mine that loses money,
but that helps them establish
a physical presence here,
in case oil is ever
discovered in the Arctic.
The upshot is that no matter
what it says on paper,
it's really hard to say that a space
isn't a part of a country,
when it looks and acts like
a part of that country.
So this is the approach
that Turkey decided to take after 1974.
The Turkish government put
out radio advertisements
to rural parts of Turkey,
telling low-wage workers
that they could resettle on a
nearby Mediterranean island,
where they would be given a
home, a farm, animals, money.
More than 30,000 Turkish
Nationals took them up
on the offer, and headed
for the occupied island.
They filled these empty Greek homes.
They started a new life.
- [Interviewer] What do
you pay for the house?
- For the time, we don't
pay. Hasn't come up yet.
- [Interviewer] It's the
property of the government
now, is it?
- Yes, it is, yes.
- [Interviewer] Are you worried, at all,
that the original owner might somehow
have some opportunity to get it back?
- I don't think so, no, (indistinct).
- [Interviewer] You just don't
think it'll happen, you mean?
- No, I don't think so, no.
- [Johnny] But here's the thing.
Turkish Cypriots are not the
same as Turkish Nationals.
While they both have cultural
roots in the Ottoman Empire,
many of these Turkish
settlers align politically,
culturally, and religiously
with mainland Turkey,
more than with Cyprus.
- Many Turkish Cypriots
feel that their lifestyle,
and their culture, are being threatened
by the current Turkish government.
By building Mosques,
by trying to take part
in the change in the culture.
Generally speaking, Turkey
Cypriots are very secular,
part of an island, easygoing lifestyle,
maybe even less religious,
or enjoy their beliefs in privacy.
- (speaking foreign language)
- [Johnny] In the decades that followed,
Turkish mainlanders kept coming.
- (speaking foreign language)
- [Johnny] Over the years,
Turkey helped the Cypriots
establish a new government.
They renamed all of the
villages from Greek names,
to Turkish names, and eventually,
they declared this place a new country,
the Turkish Republic of
Northern Cyprus, or TRNC.
The rest of the world,
of course, rejected this.
This was not a new country, it was still
the Republic of Cyprus,
with just 35% of it
being occupied by Turkey.
And indeed, efforts from
the international community
focused on reunifying this island,
making it one Cyprus.
Turkey knew that the
only way to stop this,
was not just to send
people to occupy the land,
but also to make this place
feel and look like a real country,
one that is deeply reliant on
Turkey; facts on the ground.
So I'm now at a base for the Coast Guard,
about to get on a boat.
Wow, okay.
Good morning, hi there.
- [Male Speaker 4] Good morning, sir.
- [Johnny] How are you?
(tense electronic music)
I rode with the TRNC Coast Guard.
It was kind of a bizarre experience.
Halfway through the ride,
the leader of the boat,
who was sort of escorting us on this trip,
started prompting me to
get shots of this flag,
the TRNC flag, which looks
very similar to Turkey's flag.
He asked me a few times to get this shot.
For all of the military
and government ridealongs
I've been on, this was a strange moment.
And it clearly revealed
why the TRNC Coast Guard
let me come here in the first place,
why it was fairly easy to get access.
Turkey wants the world to see
that this is a real country.
"Look, it has a real
military with a real flag."
But in reality, if you
peek under the surface,
you'll see that this TRNC
military has anywhere
from 3-9,000 troops on the island;
compare that with the
more than 30,000 troops
that Turkey has here.
And, in fact, two thirds
of the entire TRNC budget
is funded by Turkey.
The TRNC is a place sponsored by Turkey.
(tense electronic music)
And they eagerly let me
come cover their military,
or get shots of their border crossing,
so that I would broadcast
these "facts on the ground"
to the world, to show how
country-like this place feels.
And indeed, admittedly, it does.
(energetic music)
So the big question I have is, "Why?"
Why does Turkey do this thing
that the rest of the world condemns,
just so that they can
have 35% of this island?
The first answer to that is
just general geopolitics,
whose tagline is, "Control more land."
Especially land that recently
had a deposit of oil
and gas off its shores.
- [Male Speaker 4] The
Greek-dominated Republic of Cyprus
is now set to profit from natural gas.
- So on the agenda, in Brussels,
yesterday, was-
- (multiple voices) Turkey.
- Turkey's drilling for oil and gas.
- In the hotly-contested
East Mediterranean.
- Off the coast of Cyprus.
- [Male Speaker 4] People here are worried
about another war.
- [Male Speaker] A single incident
could easily draw the region
into a devastating war.
- [Johnny] Turkey claims that all of this
is the economic water of the TRNC,
but no one on Earth would let that happen.
So in response, Turkey opened
a new base on the TRNC,
with drones and other
military infrastructure,
just to reinforce their
claim with firepower.
The other major reason for all of this
is just straight-up nationalism.
The current president
in Turkey is sort of a,
"Make Turkey great again," kind of guy.
Owning Cyprus is just another place
for him to spread that
ideology and religious fervor.
And PS, that Turkish Nationalism,
is also spread vigorously
by his army of Turkish
Nationalists on the internet.
You'll definitely see them in
the comments of this video.
But yeah, Turkey wants to
keep this part of Cyprus.
They don't want it to
fall back into the hands
of the Republic of Cyprus,
where it would become
a member of the EU, and part of a country
that isn't super friendly to Turkey.
Okay, so geopolitics, blah-blah-blah.
What about the people?
The people who are actually
living here every day.
We can look on a map all day long,
but I came here to talk to
the people who live in a place
that is more and more reliant on Turkey.
(energetic electronic music)
(soft electronic music)
How do you feel about
Turkey, the country, today,
and its presence here?
Does it feel protective?
- To be honest, to me, it
doesn't feel protective.
It feels rather like
digesting conquered territory.
That might sound extreme to
some, but that's how I see it.
- You live in a country
that the rest of the world
doesn't recognize as a country.
- Yes.
- How does that feel to you?
- It feels secluded, to be honest.
- [Johnny] This pseudo-country
of Northern Cyprus
isn't able to trade
with any other country,
any goods that come in here,
have to go through Turkey first.
Any goods that go out of
here, have to go to Turkey,
and be handled or modified in some way,
so that they are technically
Turkish, all of a sudden,
and then they can be
shipped out into the world.
- [Male Speaker] Only 63
foreign ships were handled
at Famagusta last year, for the
regime is not yet recognized
by anyone but Turkey.
The biggest single user
of Famagusta's port
is the Turkish military;
137 ships last year.
- I have to say this, like
everything in the TRNC's
like a cheap knockoff of
the original. (chuckles)
- And then you have the airport
here in Northern Cyprus.
Again, it's sort of an illegal airport,
it only flies to Turkey, it
can't fly to any other country.
- It feels like there's the TRNC,
and then there's the world.
- Yeah.
- So everything else is different here.
- Most of the diplomas
that you get from TRNC,
they aren't recognized
anywhere in the world.
I think there are exceptions, to like,
one or two universities, but most of them
are practically useless if you're planning
to go abroad, because
they're not recognized.
- [Johnny] All of this
makes the people here
locked into Turkey's world,
for trade, for business, for security,
for government funding, it's all Turkey.
- [Male Speaker]
Everywhere, mainland Turkey
casts a giant shadow.
What then of the Turkish Cypriot identity?
Cyprus is already divided.
Will the North soon become
just another Turkish province?
(slow electronic music)
- (speaking foreign language)
- Well, ultimately, I believe that Cyprus
belongs to Cypriots, Greek Cypriots
and Turkish Cypriots alike,
but they should have the final say
in the future of their country.
- [Johnny] And that gets
us back to this pipeline.
The one that sends water from
Southern Turkey into Cyprus
to provide drinking water
for the people here.
Is it starting to make more sense now?
I called this "an umbilical
cord", because it represents
just one of the many ways that Turkey,
who calls themselves the mother country,
has made the TRNC reliant on them.
Now, listen, it's one thing
to fund the government
and the military, and be the only gateway
to the global economy.
But this is water, for
heaven's sake; it's survival.
This is a much deeper level of reliance.
This reliance was made very clear in 2020,
when the pipeline burst.
The towns that have their water systems
now linked into this pipeline
were without water for
days, sometimes weeks.
They eventually fixed the
pipeline, but all of this revealed
just how reliant these people now are,
on the country across the sea.
Turkish Cypriots, of course,
would never go for this
if they had another option.
But the reality is, they don't,
because they needed water.
So they took the gift.
- They'll say, "We came and
we saved you, you need us."
So all of this- sort of
like, yes, they did help
when we needed it, back in the day.
But just feels like now
we're being held hostage
by the fact that they helped.
- [Johnny] All of these
reliances on Turkey,
make it less and less
likely that this island
will ever find unity again.
With every Turkish
National that moves here,
or every bit of money
used to build the military
or government here, with
every infrastructure project,
real peace on this island
becomes less and less possible.
Facts on the ground,
more and more every year,
just as Turkey intended.
But listen, I want to
make one thing clear.
This isn't as simple as Turkey
holding the people of Cyprus hostage,
it's more nuanced than that.
Especially if you were a Turkish Cypriot
in the '60s and '70s.
- (speaking foreign language)
- [Johnny] These were
minorities who were bullied
and massacred, and they found refuge
when Turkey came in to save them.
That's a reality that's
not easy to forget.
But in the end, it's
clear that even despite
the pro-Turkey feelings
among some Turkish Cypriots,
what Turkey has done to this island
is prioritized Turkey's interests,
and not the interests of the people.
Who, even though they
received all of these gifts,
really pay the price of being
Turkey's political pond.
Something that has been
a theme for the people
on this island for literally
thousands of years.
(slow electronic music)